[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مع مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر
بركه احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر
من كل زواياه ومن جميع الجوانبه
تقارير عن تجهيز الفانتاجون خطه الطوارئ
لحرب مع اسرائيل مع ايران واسرائيل تحذر
الصراع قد يصل نقطه لا عوده
[تصفيق]
روسيا تحشد نيرانها في ضخموت بحثا عن اول
نصر في نصف عام
حائره بين التضحيه والانسحاب التكتيكي
تعتقد القوه الامنيه هنا نما يجري في
المخيم هو استغلال للاطفال والمراهقين
العربيه في قلب مخيم الهول داعش يحاول
العوده مرتكزا على فكره وبعض من السلاح
والمال المهرب
والدينا ايضا في العربيه 360 اردوغان
يتمثل للموعد الانتخابات والعربيه ترصد
احلامنا خابين جنوب تعساء الخيام
ومحظوظي الحاويه
[موسيقى]
اكدت صحيفه ان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
البانتاجون وضعت ميزانيه الطوارئ لحرب مع
ايران وبتحليل الصحيفه للميزانيه وضع
ميزانيه تحت اسم خطه دعم الحارس وذلك في
حال اندلاع حرب مع ايران ورفضت القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه التعليق على هذه الخطه
الا انها اكدت ان ايران تظل مصدر التهديد
الاول في الشرق الاوسط واضافت القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه ان واشنطن لم تتردد في
الدفاع عن مصالحها في الشرق الاوسط
واخر الاخبار العاجله الان على الشاشه عن
قائد قوه ايران البحريه يقول ان اجراء
مناورات لقوات اجنبيه في الخليج يعد
تهديدا لبلاده
هذا هو من المتوقع ان يصل وزير الدفاع
الامريكي الى اسرائيل الاربعاء المقبل في
زياره تستغرق يومين حسب ما افاد موقع
اكسيوس تتزامن هذه الزياره مع جهود تقوم
بها واشنطن لتهدئه التوترات في الضفه
الغربيه كما تاتي على خلفيه المخاوف
المتزايده بشان التقدم الكبير في برنامج
ايران النووي
وفي اسرائيل قال عديت باسيوكو وهو رئيس
هيئه العمليات في الجيش ان ايران ليست
مشكله اسرائيل فقط وانما تشكل خطرا على ان
المنطقه واستقرارها باسرها وقالبا انه
بالاضافه للتهديد النووي فان انتشار
الطائرات المسيره وانتهاك حريات الملاحه
الدوليه في المنطقه عاملان اضافيا لخطر
النظام الايراني واعرب عن اعتقاده بان
الصراع مع ايران قد يصل الى نقطه لا عوده
مؤكدا ان اسرائيل تواصل تسريع استعداداتها
لاتخاذ الاجراءات اذا لزم الامر
هذا واجرى الجيش الايراني والحرس الثوري
تدريبات دفاعيه مشتركه لمحاكاه هجوم على
مواقع نوويه وعسكريه وقال ان التدريبات
غطت ثلثي المجال الجوي للبلاد
[موسيقى]
معنا مراسل العربيه اهلا بك معنا
دقه
واحترام ان ترسبت في المؤسسات الرسميه
الامريكيه
متحدث باسم عندما سالته عن هذا الموضوع
قال انا اعرف ان هذا الموضوع قد نشر ولكن
لن ادلي باي تعليق السبب هو ان مصداقيه
انتر سبت ليست عاليه جدا ولكن يجب ان نضيف
انها الامريكيين عندما تتحدث اليهم في هذا
الموضوع يعتبرون ان وزاره الدفاع والقياده
المركزيه هم مؤسساتان عسكريتان بعمليات
تخطيط واسعه لا يخوضون في هذه المواضيع
كلها وفي تفاصيلها ولكن يجب ان نفهم دائما
ان لدى الامريكيين قطط لكل شيء
وبانتظار العمل بهذه الخطط من هي الاجهزه
والمؤسسات الرئيسيه المعنيه بهذا الموضوع
حاليا وما الاجراءات التي تتخذها
يعني قبيل القيام بمثل هذه الضربه ان رات
نفسها ملزمه بها
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه والقياده المركزيه
هم مسؤولتان عن منطقه الشرق الاوسط ولو
كان هناك اي تهديدات فاننا سوف نسمع اولا
من هاتين المؤسستين يجب ان نقول ايضا ان
الاداره الامريكيه بشكل عام والمؤسسات
العسكريه بشكل خاص تعتبر ان ايران هي
تهديد للامن في هذه المنطقه وكل المساعي
التي يقوم بها وزير الدفاع او القياده
المركزيه او المسؤولين في الاداره
الامريكيه بالتعاون مع اعضاء مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وبقي الاطراف في المنطقه مثل
الاردن واسرائيل ومصر وغيرها كلها تصب في
جانب واحد وهو مواجهه المخاطر الايرانيه
ماذا عن دول المنطقه المعنيه بهذا الموضوع
بشكل مباشر غير اسرائيل كيف تنظر واشنطن
في هذه المرحله تحديدا
بشان دورها
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انجزت خطوات جيده بتنسيق دفاعاتها وقوتها
الامنيه والاستخباراتيه مع دول مجلس
التعاون الخليجي شهدنا منذ حوالي
الاسبوعين اجتماعا مهما جدا في الرياض بين
الامريكيين ومجموعه مجلس التعاون الخليجي
لتنسيق الدفاعات بين الامريكيين وشركاء في
هذه المنطقه
لمواجهه المخاطر الامريكيه الامريكيون
ارادون جدا عن هذا التنسيق الجديد يخفف من
الحضور الامريكي العسكري في هذه المنطقه
يستند اكثر الى القوه العسكريه الموجوده
في هذه المنطقه وينسق فيما بينها اكان على
الصعيد البحري او على الصعيد الجوي وخصوصا
تنسيق الدفاعات الجويه بمعنى ان واشنطن
اذا ركزنا قليلا على هذه الجزئيه تريد ان
يكون هناك رد مشترك
على ايران ان قررت القيام بضربه من هذا
النوع
حتى الان يتحدث الامريكيون عن دفاعات ولا
يتحدثون عن هجمات ولكن لو تحدثنا عن موضوع
الهجمات فكل مره تتحدث الى مسؤول في وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه يشير الى ان هناك مناوره
ضخمه قامت بها القوات
الامريكيه مع القوات الاسرائيليه وهذه
المناوره شاركت فيها قوات استراتيجيه
امريكيه تمكن الامريكيون من ارسال قوات
ضخمه اكان او غيرها
وبالاضافه اليهم القوات المشاه الى اراض
بعيده عنهم اي الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط اجر
مناورات كبيره وضخمه
من ناحيه النوعيه ومن ناحيه الحجم
وبالتالي اثبتوا انهم قادرون على الوصول
الى المنطقه باسرع وقت وايضا الخروج من
المنطقه وبالتالي عمليات التنسيق عمليات
الضخامه كلها اصبحت متوفره بالنسبه لهم
شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات مراسل
العربيه من واشنطن تحياتي اليك
اكد مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
رافاييل جروسيا او سيزور ايران الجمعه
لحضور اجتماعات رفيعه المستوى وتاتي زياره
بعد تاكيد المفتشين وجود جزيئات يورو مخصب
بنسبه تقترب من 90% في فوردو الامر الذي
تصر طهران على وصفه بالحادث العارض
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو اعرب
في ختام زياره لبغداد عن امله في اعاده
العمل بالاتفاق النووي الايراني مره اخرى
مستحيل ان اتي الى العراق ولا اناقش
العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده وايران
ولذلك فانه من الواضح انني ناقشت هذه
المساله ولكن هذه القضيه لا يمكن حلها بين
الامم المتحده والعراق اود التاكيد على
دعم القوي لخطه العمل المشتركه واؤمن ان
الاتفاق النووي احد اهم الانتصارات
السياسيه في الوقت الراهن واعمل ان نتغلب
على الصعوبات في تنفيذه
ونبقى مع الشان الايراني فالنظام هناك
يتجسس على هواتف وخدمه الانترنت لمواطنيه
لكن المفاجاه ان هذا الامر قد يكون حدث
بمساعده شركات اجنبيه تقرير لايران
انترناشونال يقول انه من الممكن ان تكون
شركات
الكنديه والتلسي البريطانيه
الروسيه تعاونت مع النظام في تنفيذ نظام
سيام لتتبع الهواتف المحموله للمتظاهرين
افاد التقرير بان صيام هو نظام يحتوي على
قدرات تجسس خاصه تستهدف شبكات الهاتف
المحمول الايرانيه وباستخدام هذه الاداه
يمكن للنظام ابطاء او قطع الانترنت عن
الهواتف المحموله وكسر تشفير المكالمات
الهاتفيه وتتبع تحركات الافراد او
المجموعات وفقا لخبراء يمتلك صيام خاصيه
تمكنه من ابطاء انترنت المستخدم من الجيل
الثالث او الجيل الرابع لشبكات الهاتف
المحمول مع تخفيضه الى مستوى شبكه الجيل
الثاني وبالتالي يصبح اكثر عرضه للتنصت
سبق لموقع سيتيزن لاب الكندي النشر تقريرا
كشف مراسلات بين ايران وشركات ايران سال
وشركات الاجنبيه ومنها شركه بروتي الروسيه
طلب فيها مسؤول من الشركه الايرانيه ترتيب
وصول فريق تدريب الى ايران كما استفسر
المسؤول الايراني عن السياسات الحاليه
للسفر الى روسيا وامكانيه القيام بمثل هذه
الرحله
ايران انترناشونال قالت ان الشركتين
الايرانيتين همرول
ساهمتا في تطوير انظمه التجسس اثناء قمع
الانتفاضه الشعبيه مشيره الى ان الشركتين
تخططان للمشاركه في المؤتمر العالمي
للجوال في برشلونه للتعرف على احدث
التقنيات في هذا المجال وربما يتم
استخدامهما لتنفيذ مطالب مرشد ايران علي
النظام الايراني وفي اكثر من موجه احتجاج
عمل على قطع الانترنت وتقييده في وقت
تعاونت فيه شركه الهاتف المحمول
الايرانيتان بشكل وثيق مع المؤسسات
الامنيه لتوفير معلومات المستخدمين من اجل
مراقبتهم والقبض عليهم خاصه وان الشركتين
الخاصتين تنتميان لكيانات اقتصاديه تتبع
بشكل او باخر لمؤسسات خاضعه لخامنائي
وتوضح التقارير ان هذه المعلومات تتضمن
الموقع الجغرافي للاشخاص والعنوان والرمز
الوطني وسجل سجلات المكالمات وحتى السجلات
المتعلقه بانشطه الاشخاص على الانترنت
[موسيقى]
في الملف الاوكرانيه شيء ما يتغير على
الارض في ضخمه شرق اوكرانيا حتى وان تاخر
الحسم والدليل تعكسه تصريحات مؤسس فاجنر
الروسيه الذي يؤكد ان بحرا من الدماء يسيل
هناك كما يعكسه التخبط في التصريحات
الاوكرانيه بينما يقول ان انسحابا تكتيكيا
قد يجري ومن يؤكد ان التعزيزات في طريقها
للبلده وبشكل عاجل
مدينه باخموت الاوكرانيه تعيش على صفيح
ساخن
المسؤولون الاوكران اعترفوا بصعوبه
المعركه في باخمت
الوضع في مدينه باخموت الاوكرانيه على
الجبهه الشرقيه اصبح اكثر فاكثر صعوبه
القوات الاوكرانيه قد تنسحب من بخمه شرق
البلاد
الا ان الجيش الاوكراني كان له تفسيره
الخاص لفكره الانسحاب
اذا راينا ان التهديد اكبر من الحاجه
للسيطره على الارض فاننا سننسحب لكن
بطريقه منظمه
على الجانب الاخر روسيا تعترف بدراوه
القتال مع القوات الاوكرانيه
حذيفه عادل ومن موسكو كاتيا طعمه اهلا
بكما وابدا معك حذيفه اذا سمحتي لاعرف منه
حقيقه الموقف الاوكراني العسكري الان وفقا
لاخر التصريحات بخصوص الانسحاب او التعزيز
تحياتي طاهر لك ولزميلك كاتيا في الحقيقه
الجانب الاوكراني يقول ان تم تاويل حديث
السيد الكسندر روجانسكي مستشار الرئيس
فلادي مرسي عندما تحدث الى صحفي
وقال ان
السؤال كان بالتحديد هل هنالك اي يعني
توجه للانسحاب من مدينه باخوت فقال
الروجاسكي ان حتى هذه اللحظه لا توجد اي
لا يوجد اي قرار اتخذ بشان الانسحاب من
باقمه ولكن عمليه الانسحاب هي ايضا نظر من
قبل السلطات وقال ايضا ان في اجتماع هيئه
الاركان المشتركه يتم اتخاذ القرار وهذا
الاجتماع بهذا الخصوص لم ينعقد بعد ولكن
هذا الخيار موجود ويتم النظر اليه واذا تم
الانسحاب من باخ يتم الانسحاب انسحاب
استراتيجي بشكل منظم وقال ايضا اننا جهزنا
دفاعاتنا الهندسيه في غرب مدينه با ق موت
حتى اذا حدث هذا الانسحاب الدفاعات جاهزه
حتى لا يتقدم الروس بسرعه وبالتالي ساعود
اليك بالموضوع الميداني بالوضع الميداني
على الارض بناء على هذه المعطيات ولكن
اذهب الى كاتيا طعمي الان من موسكو لنقف
على حقيقه تصريحات الروسيه الرسميه او تلك
التي تصدر عن فاجنر ربما
بشان الوضع في ضخمه
مرحبا طاهر بالفعل التصريح اللافت كان
اليوم من رئيس قوات فاغنر الخاصه الذي
تحدث عن ان هناك مقاومه كبيره من الجانب
الاوكراني في المعارك في باخموت قال ان
الامدادات لا تتوقف الاعداد القوات هناك
تزداد ولا يوجد اي مؤشرات لاستسلام القوات
الاوكرانيه طبعا هناك كان ايضا تصريحات
سابقه لقوات الانفصاليه التي تحدثت عن
تقدم للقوات الروسيه وقوات فاكثر الخاصه
على الارض هناك بعد استلائها على مناطق
متاخمه للمدينه ومحاوله تطويقها من الشمال
ومن الجنوب من اجل قطع الامدادات العسكريه
على القوات الاوكرانيه التي تتواجد في
داخل المدينه اذا هي المعارك محتدمه وهناك
تقدم طبعا لقوات الروسيه وهو لو كان بطيئا
ولكنه تقدم بالنسبه لي ايضا كان قد تحدث
الرئيس الرئيس القوات فاجنر الخاصه عن
امكانيه استراع المدينه فقط خلال اسابيع
وليس خلال ايام بسبب صعوبه الوضع هناك عن
معارك المشتده طبعا
حذيفه عادل من ما الذي تقوله
الصحافه والمسؤولون الاوكران فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الميداني الان ووضع الناس هناك
نعم في الحقيقه قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه الكسانسكي اعلن انه سيدفع
بمزيد من التعزيزات والقوات الى باخد تم
الاعلان عن ذلك اليوم من قبل نائمه وزير
الدفاع ان مولر ايضا طبعا وهو المتحدث
باسم القوات في الشرق اعلن ايضا وتحدث
بشكل واسع عن هذا الامر خاص بعد تلك
التصريحات التي تحدثت عن اهميه القوات
الاوكرانيه الانسحاب من باقود وقال اننا
ما زلنا نسيطر على المدينه نحافظ على
جبهاتنا من الجبهات الثلاث لقواتنا لا
تسمح للقوات الروسيه بعمل اكمال عمليه
الحصار لهذه المدينه ايضا تحدث عن القوات
الروسيه التي تقاتل قال هي من اشد قوات
فاغنر تدريبا وكفاءه وهي بقوات لها خبره
قاتلت كما قال في سوريا وقتلت في مناطق
مختلفه وتم الدفع بها الى هذه الجبهه
اعترف بان الوضع صعب جدا في باق موت ولكنه
يقول اننا ما زلنا نحافظ على جميع جبهاتنا
القوات الاوكرانيه تسيطر على المدينه لا
يوجد اي عمليه اختراق واي عمليه هجوم
ومنهج ودخول الى عمق مدينه باغموت وقال
نحقق نجاح كبير في ابقاء الجبهه كما هي
عليه هو ما زالت التعزيزات تصل الى القوات
الاوكرانيه في تلك الجبهه تمام الخطه
الروسيه واضحه لمرحله ما بعد مخبوط لا
يبدو ان هناك نيه للتراجع قيده ام ملاع
عنها باعتبارها استراتيجيه جدا وبالتالي
ما هي المراحل التي يمكن ان نتصورها لاحقا
كاولويات عسكريه لا يمكن ان تفرط فيها
يعني العمليه العسكريه كما تعلم طاهر دخلت
العام عامها الثاني كان هناك طبعا
بالتاكيد تصريحات الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين عن طبعا تغييرات كانت قد صدرت في
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه لقاده العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه هناك لذلك قد يكون هناك
تغيير في الايام اللاحقه كما يتحدث بعض
الخبراء في بعض السيطره على مدينه باخمد
وطبعا اريد ان انه بالتوازي مع هذا هناك
اتهامات قناه قد وجهتها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
وموسكو بتحديد نحو مدينه
التي قالت ان هناك تجمع لقوات اوكرانيه
بجانب هذه المنطقه لذلك لم يستبعد خبراء
ان يكون هناك ايضا
امتداد او توسيع في العمليه العسكريه لتصل
الى مدينه او منطقه بريدناستروبيا في
مولدوفا وتقطع بالتالي لتزداد مساحه
المعارك وتقطع بالتالي مدينه او مناطق
دومباس طاهر شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه
المعلومات كاتيا وحذيفه عادل من كياف
تحياتي اليكما
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا رغم كارثه الزلزال
وتداعياته اردوغان يتوعد منتقديه اراكم في
الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ومن جديد حمل وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني بلينكن الرئيس
الروسي حمله مسؤوليه انهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا والدخول في مفاوضات سلام جاده
لا احد يريد السلام بشكل عاجل بقدر ما
يحتاجه الاوكرانيون هناك ضحايا في كل يوم
بسبب العدوان الروسي الان نحن جميعا نعلم
الحقيقه ببساطه بان الحرب يمكن ان تنتهي
غدا او اليوم اذا اراد الرئيس بوتين اتخاذ
هذا القرار هو الذي بدا الحرب ويمكن ان
يقوم بانهائها
وفيما يتعلق بمبادره الصين لاحلال السلام
قال بلنكن انباكين يجب ان تحدد دورها
كوسيط وليس كطرف يغذي الحرب
[موسيقى]
الصين لديها طريقان تسير من خلالهما فهي
تضع نفسها خارج الحسابات وتقدم نفسها كقوه
قادره على طرح السلام العالمي امام الراي
العام وفي الوقت ذاته تغذي الحرب التي
بداتها روسيا وتشعل نيرانها
الصراع بين الولايات المتحده والصين صراع
وجود بحسب لجنه فرعيه بمجلس النواب
الامريكي والتي دعت لمواجهه التهديدات
الصينيه اعضاء لجنه شؤون المنافسه
الاستراتيجيه بين الولايات المتحده والحزب
الشيوعي الصيني بالكونجرس حذرت حذروا خلال
جلسه استماع اوليه من التهديدات
الاقتصاديه والامنيه التي تشكلها الحكومه
الصينيه داعين الاداره الامريكيه للتصرف
بشكل عاجل لمواجهتها انطلاق اعمال اللجنه
ياتي في فتره عدم استقرار بين واشنطن
وبيكين وبعد اسابيع من تحليق منطاد تجسس
صيني فوق الولايات المتحده في وقت يواصل
فيه النواب الجمهوريون مهاجمه الرئيس جو
بايدن بسبب رده فعله على حادثه منطاد
التجسس الصيني شهدت اللجنه توافقا بين
اعضائها من الحزبين الرئيس الجمهوري للجنه
وهو ماي جالاكر عبر عن امله في ان تساعد
اللجنه في تشكيل سياسات وتشري عات تتعلق
بالعلاقات مع الصين يمكن لها ان تكسب
تاييد الحزبين مضيفا ان سياسه واشنطن على
مدى السنوات العشر القادمه ستمهد طريق
لمئات الاعوام القادمه على حد قوله
هذه ليست مباراه تينيس مهذبه هذا صراع
وجود حول الشكل الذي ستبدو عليه الحياه في
القرن الحادي والعشرين واكثر الحريات
الاساسيه على المحك
على الجانب الاخر قال النائب الديمقراطي
الرجاء كريشنا مرسي ان الولايات المتحده
تدافع عن مصالحها وانها لا تريد حربا مع
الصين لكانت بارده ام ساخنه ولا حتى صدام
حضارات اعتبر النائب ان واشنطن بحاجه
للتحرك سريعا لرفع مستوى التنافس مع بكين
والوقوف بوجهها
على مدى العقود الثلاثه الماضيه استهان كل
من الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين بالحزب
الشيوعي الصيني وافترضوا ان التجاره
والاستثمار سيؤديان حتما الى الديمقراطيه
وللمزيد من الامن بمنطقه المحيطين الهندي
والهادئ بما في ذلك جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
وبدلا من ذلك حدث العكس
مع اقتراب الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
العام المقبل ومحاوله الجمهوريين اظهار ما
يصفونه بضاع في موقف اداره بايدن تجاه
الصين الا ان عده ملفات متعلقه بباكين
اظهرت شبهه اجماع من الحزبين كالاجراءات
التي تحضر تطبيق تيك توك اضافه للحد من
الصادرات الامريكيه وتجاره التقنيه الى
الصين
جورنال قالت ان الخطابات والشهادات لم تكن
جديده الا ان اللجنه تهدف لارسال رساله
قويه للصين على صعيد الشارع اثار منتقدون
اللجنه الفرعيه بمجلس النواب مخاوف من ان
الخطاب التصعيدي الذي يصف الصين بعدو
الولايات المتحده من شانه زياده المشاعر
المعاديه للمواطنين الامريكيين من اصول
الاسيويه وبالتالي تصاعد نسبه حوادث
الكراهيه
نبقى مع التنافس الامريكي الصيني والى
مقال راي تحليلي نشرته نيويورك تايمز
فبحسب الكاتب وهو رص بابج الحرب مع الصين
لن تكون مثل اي حرب وجهها الامريكيون من
قبل الكاتب قال ان الشراره الاكثر احتمالا
لهذه الحرب ستكون غزو الصين لتايوان
واعتبر الكاتب ان الحزب الشيوعي الصيني
اصبح قويا بما يكفي على الصعود للعسكريه
والاقتصاديه والصناعيه للاستيلاء على
تايوان وتحدي الولايات المتحده بشكل مباشر
من اجل التفوق الاقليمي لكن لماذا ستكون
هذه الحرب حاله وقوعها مختلفه عن غيرها
بابج اضاف ان الامريكيين اعتادوا ان يرسل
جيشهم للقتال بعيدا عن الوطن الا ان الصين
كقوه قادره على نقل الحرب الى الداخل
الامريكي عسكريا باستهداف البنيه التحتيه
الامريكيه وايضا بالهجمات الالكترونيه
وبالامكان ان تضرب الصين ايضا اهدافا
عسكريه للولايات المتحده في جغرافيا
حلفائها كاليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وغيرهما
المقال قال ان الصين تعد الان القوه
الصناعيه العالميه المهيمنه التجاريا
وعسكريا وضرب مثلا بحرب اوكرانيا عندما
ادى تزويد كياف بالمعدات العسكريه الى
استفاد المخزونات الامريكيه لبعض الانظمه
العسكريه الرئيسه وهو ما قد يستغرق اعواما
لاعاده بنائها اضاف الكاتب ان حرب
اوكرانيا تعتبر صغيره نسبيا اذا ما قورنت
بحرب كبرى في المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
[موسيقى]
اضافه للتوترات السياسيه والعسكريه
المحتمله اثار تقرير وكاله بلومبرج اليوم
مخاوف من سباق تسلح نووي الوكاله قالت ان
روسيا صدرت ما يقرب من سبعه اعضاف كميه
اليورينيوم عالي التخصيب الى الصين خلال
الفتره ما بين سبتمبر وديسمبر من العام
الماضي بحسب بلومبرج تم تصدير هذه المواد
من روسيا الى الصين لاستخدامها في مفعل
جديد بجزيره
تشامبياو النائيه ما يتيح القدره على
انتاج بلوتونيوم يمكن استخدامه لاحقا في
الاسلحه النوويه
نقلت في تقريرها عن مسؤولي مخابرات
امريكيين توقعهم انه عندما يبدا العمل
بالمفاعل الصيني هذا العام فسيكون بوسع
بيكين زياده مخزون رؤوس الحربيه النوويه
بنحو اربعه اضعاف في السنوات الاثني عشر
المقبله اذا المقصود الاعوام المقبله وهو
ما من شانه ان يسمح للصين بمضاهات
الترسانه النوويه التي تنشرها الولايات
المتحده وروسيا حاليا
تاتي مساعيد صين لتوسيع اسلحه هذا الذريه
في وقت تتعرض فيه المعاهده التي تحد من
المخزونات الاستراتيجيه لكل من الولايات
المتحده وروسيا لخطر الانهيار في ظل الحرب
على اوكرانيا بعد الموقف الروسي الاخير
الذي نعرفه جميعا حول هذه المعاهده من
واشنطن معنا دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في
الشؤون السياسيه الامريكيه ونعود اليها
بعد قليل لم يكن جاهزا الان نتابع
[موسيقى]
داخل مخيم الهول في سوريا يتوقف الزمن
مشاهد العنف والتطرف التي رافق التنظيم
داعش في المناطق التي كانت يوما خاضعه له
تتكرر هنا
لكن الاخطر هذه الايام هو ما رصدته
العربيه خلال جولتها الحصريه جيل جديد
للتنظيم داخل المخيم الذي يسجل ولادات
شهريه لنساء داعش اللواتي يحملن دون
ازواجهن عبر استغلال المراهقين والذكور
المتعاطفين مع التنظيم لهذه الغايه هذا
فضلا عن عمليات تهريب للسلاح والاموال
يشرح القائمون على اداره مخيم الهول خريطه
اقسامه قبل جوله الاستكشاف الوضع داخله
لكنهم يقولون ان ما نراه هنا غير كامل
واعداد قاطنين مخيم غير دقيقه فهناك حالات
زواج غير موثقه ومواليد جدد يتفاجئون
بوجودهم في خيم الاجنبيات كلما شنوا
عمليات مداهمه وهي خيم يفترض انها تضم
نساء الدواعش واطفالهن فقط فالازواج اما
في السجون او قتله تصريح مفاجئ بدا انه
يحتاج شرحا
لنفهم القصه توجهنا الى دلبرين كوباني
القياديه في وحده حمايه المراه في اقليم
الجزيره وهي كانت اشرفت على حمله
الانسانيه والامر التي شمتها القوات
الامنيه ضد خلايا داعش في الهول
يجب ان يكون قسم الاجنبيات في المخيم دون
رجال اثناء العمليه اكتشفنا انهم اخفوا
المراهقين الذكور في الانفاق التي حفروها
كانوا يفعلون ذلك حتى لا تتمكن قوات الامن
من اكتشافهم انهم يستخدمون هؤلاء
المراهقين لاغراض الانجاب
هناك لاجئون عراقيون وبعض النازحين
السوريين يذهبون خلصتا الى قسم الاجانب
للزواج من اجنبيات انهم يستخدمون كل هذه
الطرق لانجاب المزيد من الاطفال
تعتقد القوى الامنيه هنا انما يجري في
المخيم هو استغلال للاطفال والمراهقين
بقرار من التنظيم لذا تقول انها طلبت من
النساء في قسم الاجنبيات تسليم الاطفال
فوق السن الخامسه عشره لاخدهم الى مراكز
منفصله كما شنت عمليات لمنع تسلل رجال من
اقسام السوريين والعراقيين الى هذا القسم
لغرض الزواج من الاجنبيات
حاولنا الحصول على رد او تعليق نساء
الدواعش لكن دون جدوى
غادرنا قسم الاجنبيات واتجهنا لاقسام
السوريين والعراقيين وهي مخصصه لداعشيات
سوريات وعراقيات كما تضم نساء وازواجهن
نزحوا من مناطق السيطره داعش وهؤلاء
يقولون المسؤولون عن الامن هنا انه يصعب
الجزم بعدم ارتباطهم بالتنظيم سابقا او
بخلاياه داخل المخيم حاليا
هذا ناصح سوري يروي بعض ما يجري داخل
المخيم
سمعت الموضوع يعني اكثر من اربعه
ان الشرع يعني اربعه
لماذا حتى في واحد معنا مطلوب وخربان منهم
قايلين لزوجته تخلعيه
يعني
يجعل اعداد المواليد شهريا اكبر من
المتوقع
[موسيقى]
عدد الولادات هي كثيره جدا يعني بالشهر
بالشهر اللي فات كان عنا 61 حاله ولاده
باقسام العراقيين فقط
[موسيقى]
جيل جديد باعداد كبيره ينشا في خيام
الدواعش في الهول على الغالب يحاول
التنظيم بهذا ضمان استمراريته وتعقيد مهمه
محاربته صار بن عيشوبات العربيه الحسكه
[موسيقى]
واخبار عاجله جديده عن خارجيه الامريكيه
تقول تصريحات وزير ماليه اسرائيل عن محو
قريه حواره غير مسؤوله ومقززه
وبروكسيل ايضا قبل قليل حضاره الطهران على
الافراج عن مواطن بلجيكي يعمل في الاراده
نعود الى شان الامريكي الصيني معنا من
واشنطن دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير الامريكيه
اهلا بك معنا دكتور
اذا سالتك ان تعطينا توصيفا لطبيعه الحال
الامريكيه الصينيه الان في هذه المرحله اي
توصيف يمكن ان نعطيها
متوتره قلق شديد امريكي لكن لا يقين
امريكي بخصوص نيات الصين نحو روسيا
لكن المؤشرات السلبيه تتصاعد والفجوه بين
الطرفين تزداد هل يثبت لك يوما بعد يوم
بان الصين في الموضوع الروسي تتاخر كثيرا
لتؤمن ما يمكن تامينه في اطار العلاقه
بينها وبين واشنطن اولا قبل ان تحاول ان
تدخل على الخط يعني في غموض بسياساتها
ورغم الاتهامات الغربيه ولكن ايضا واشنطن
غير واضحه تماما وتتبع سياسه الغموض
الاستراتيجي في بعض الملفات خاصه في موضوع
تايوان
يعني الصين حذرت جدا تريد ان تبقي على
علاقاتها مع روسيا لكن تستفيد من شركائها
الاقتصاديين
المهمين
وهنا نتحدث عن الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده هذا جانب لديها ميل روسيا لاسباب
مفهومه لانه تعتقد ان الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا يمكن ان يتكرر هذا المشهد بخصوص
تايوان يعني ملف معقد لكنه لحد الان ما
تقوم به الصين يقع ضمن القانون يعني حتى
استيراد
اليورانيوم المخصب وان كان بكميات كبيره
روسيا يعني بحدود سته اطنان
روسيا المعاهده لا بد ان سنكون امام واقع
جديد
يعني يبرز الحاجه الى تفاهمات جديده ايضا
تشمل كل هذه الاطراف وليس اتفاقات مخلفات
الحرب البارده
اذا انه هذا الفهم الصيني او الروسي دقيق
يعني استيراد الصله اليورانيوم المخصب لا
يخرق القانون الولايات المتحده عندما فرضت
العقوبات على روسيا استثنت اليورانيوم
لانها هي نفسها تستورد اليورانيوم المخصب
من روسيا روسيا اكبر منتج في العالم
المفاعلات النوويه الامريكيه التي تصنع
الطاقه الكهرباء وليس الحربيه يعني تعيش
على اليورانيوم المخصب
يعني على اليورانيوم الروسي فمن حق الصين
ان تشتري لكن الاشكاليه هنا القلق ما الذي
ستفعله الصين بهذه الكميه الكبيره هل
ستخصبه بين اثنين وثلاثه بالمئه من اجل
انتاج الطاقه كما هي تقول وتقول هذا منذ
اشهر حقيقه
اليوم كما قلنا اثار مخاوف من سباق تسلح
نووي
نعم اذا اذا استخدمت الصين هذه الكميه
لزياده يعني تخصيب 90% لا نحن ذاهبون نحو
انتاج قنابل ذريه قنابل نوويه وبامكان
الصين بالكميه الكبيره التي استوردتها من
روسيا يعني
قنبله ذريه هي تستطيع ان حولت هذه نحو
صناعه قنابل نوويه ان تتجاوز الولايات
المتحده في عدد القنابل النوويه التي
لديها من هنا القلق يعني لا يوجد ثقه بين
الطرفين بين الولايات المتحده والصين
الولايات المتحده تصير على مراقبه دقيقه
والصين لا تسمح بمثل هذه المراقبه يعني
واشياء كثيره يعني موضوع مقلق
والخطوات الصينيه بالذات في هذه المرحله
يبدو انها تستفيد من انشغال الغرب
والولايات المتحده تحديدا بموضوع اوكرانيا
وهذا ما يزيد الا الامريكي لا تبدو هذه
الخطوات انها قادمه في سياقها الصحيح رغم
ان الخطوات ذات قانونيه ما الذي سيحصل
بعدها هذا شيء اخر مفتوح لنزاع ونقاش
الخرجه الامريكيه تحث ايران على التحقيق
فيها هجمات تسميم طالبات وهناك خبر اخر عن
الخارجيه متعلق بتصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي تقول انها تصل الى حد التحريض
على العنف دكتور عقيل عباس الخبير السياسه
السياسيه الامريكيه من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه معنا تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الدفاع السعوديه الامير خالد بن
سلمان اليوم انه وقع مع نظيره البريطاني
بانس اعلان نوايا بشان مشاركه المملكه في
برنامج القدرات الجويه المستقبليه واضاف
الامير خالد عبر حسابه على تويتر ان
البرنامج سيسهم في تعزيز القدرات الدفاعيه
للمملكه وتطوير المنظومات الجويه
المستقبليه واشار وزير الدفاع السعوديه
الى انه بحث مع نظيره البريطاني التعاون
في المجال العسكري والدفاعي وسبل تعزيزه
حدد رئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان جدد
تاكيده على ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والتشريعيه ستجرى في الرابع عشر من مايو
كما كان مخططا له واستنكر اردوغان
الانتقادات المواجهه لحكومته على ادارتها
للكارثه مؤكدا ان الرد على هذه الانتقادات
سيكون في صناديق الاقتراع
الزلزال المدمر وحد معاناه الناجين فيها
الطاي صار حلمهم جميعا هو مسكن ملائم
يبداون فيه حياتهم من جديد حتى وان اختلف
وضعهم الحاليه من المساكن المتنقله الى
الحاويات الى الخيام موفدنا عبد القادر
خربوش كان هناك
[موسيقى]
لحظه حدوث الزلزال كانت كل احلام سكان هذه
الخيام تتلخص في نجاتهم ونجاه اكبر عدد من
ذويهم وبعد النجاه صاروا يحلمون بخيمه
كهذه تاويهم وتقي اجسادهم بردا الليالي
وحر الايام مرحبا هذا هوني صالون يعتبر
يعني شويه اغراض حاطينه هون لبس للاولاد
هذا هو محل منامي هاي هي الخيمه الموجوده
ساكن ببيت بيت راح كله بالكامل
وطلعت زوجتي هاي زوجتي وهي بنتي طالعت من
الانقاذ وطلعت عمي واحد بياخد راحته ببيته
ما بتلخيمه يعني هذا المؤاخذه بده يتحمم
بيته في حمام هون بدك تروح لهنيك حمام
مشترك حاويات كانت تجوب العالم محمله
بالبضائع تحولت الى بيوت يحلم بها ضحايا
الزلزال في تركيا وهي تبدو لهم قصورا
مقارنه مع الخيام
[موسيقى]
انا اعمل في الميناء واقود اله رفع
الحاويات لمده 30 عاما واليوم وبعد انهيار
بيتي بسبب زلزال صارت هذه الحاويه هي
منزلي هنا اعيش رفقه زوجتي وهذه اغراضنا
ينام برفقتنا خمسه اشخاص من عائلتنا
مرحبا بكم في بيت الجديد هنا نعيش وهذا هو
مطبخي الوضع صعب اتمنى الحصول على مسكن
لائق في اقرب وقت
لن يتوقف حلم قاطني هذه البيوت المؤقته
هنا وان طال البقاء انه التشبث بالحياه
يجعل الاحلام تكبر يوما بعد يومة هذا هو
حال الناجين من كارثه الزلزال الاكثر
تدميرا في تاريخ تركيا الحديث عبد القادر
خربوش العربيه
تتابعنا معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا مجلس
العلوم الدولي يناشد الحكومات تحركوا قبل
الكوارث وليس بعدها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعتبرت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان دعوه وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه لمحو قريه حواره غير مسؤوله
ومثيره للاشمئزاز ودعت الحكومه للتنصل
منها كان مسؤول عسكري اسرائيلي بارز اعتبر
ان قيام المستوطنين بحرق عشرات السيارات
والمنازل وهو ما حدث في بلده حواره
الفلسطينيه كان مجزره منظمه
ما حدث في حواره مذبحه منظمه من خارجين عن
القانون ننشر قواتنا قدر استطاعتنا بعد كل
هجوم هناك ظاهره من خارجين عن القانون
يذهبون الى مفترقات الطرق ويرشقون
بالحجاره ويقطعون ممرات فلسطينيه كنا
مستعدين لمثل هذا الفعل وحتى اكثر منه لكن
لم نكن جاهزين لمذبحه بهذا الحجم وهذا
العدد من الاشخاص
ابو احمد وبعد مرور ثلاثه ايام يتفقد اثار
الدمار الذي لحق بممتلكاته جراء هجوم
المستوطنين عليها بدايه الاسبوع خلال
البوابه فات من هون يعني ما صبروش من هون
وشيء خالد جوه الحوش هون عندنا كسروا
السياره وحركوها
احنا كنا فوق طبعا وممنوع حدا ينزل وممنوع
او بطخوا علينا دموع وقنابل صوت
وجيش احتلال بحرصهم كان الجنود وهاي
الواجهه اتطلع كيف كله كله
طبعا جوا الدار واحنا سبعه وجوا الدار
عندي خمس اولاد خمس اطفال عندي احنا
السبعه محصورين فوق عشرات المركبات
والمنشات احرقت وتركت خلفها كمن من الخوف
وعدم الشعور بالامان قد لا تستطيع جهود
التضامن والتعمي تبديده حديثنا عن حمايه
دوليه اشبعنا كلام اذا لم نكن نحن بحمايه
اهلنا واعتقد انه اللجان الشعبيه هي الرد
الحقيقي على كل ما يقوم به المستوطنين من
عربدي وغير ذلك المجتمع الدولي يكتب
تقارير المجتمع الدولي يدين المجتمع
الدولي يستنكر ولكن بالمجمل العام حان
الوقت انه احنا شعبيا نتصدى للمستوطنين
حواره اشبهوا بمدينه اشباح يخيم عليها
الصمت والحزن كما يمنع الجيش الاسرائيلي
اصحاب المحل التجاريه من فتح ابوابها حجم
الدمار على الارض ورائحه الحرائق في
المكان تدل على حجم الخوف الذي عاشته هذه
البلده قبل ثلاثه ايام وعلى حجم قله
الحيله في توفير الحمايه للمدنيين
الفلسطينيين من بلده حواره شمال الضفه
الغربيه خالد القاسم العربيه
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول نواصل الالتزام
بمعاهده بما في ذلك عدد الاسلحه النوويه
في اخر الاخبار العاجله اعلن برنامج شريك
عن الحزمه الاولى من مشاريع الشركات
الكبرى في السعوديه بقيمه 192 مليار ريال
لتشمل عددا من القطاعات الاستراتيجيه
والحيويه بهدف المساهمه في تعزيز النمو
الاقتصادي للمملكه التفاصيل في التقرير
الاتي
[موسيقى]
12 مشروعا لثماني شركات كبرى بقيمه 192
مليار ريال تم اطلاقها ضمن الحزمه الاولى
لبرنامج شريك بما في ذلك خمسه مشاريع
لارامكو مع عده شركات عالميه بينها توتال
وجوجل وهيونداي بميزانيه تبلغ 62 مليار
ريال وكذلك مشاريع لمعادن والمتقدمه
برنامج استهدف فصول استثمارات الشركات
الكبرى الخمسه تريليون حتى عام 2030
الجانب هذا جانب التمكين اليوم اعلنا عن
[موسيقى]
مشاريع ل 12 مشروع لثمان شركات باستثمارات
اجماليه لهذه المشاريع ب 1992 مليار حصه
الشركات منها 122 120 مليار هذه المشاريع
لها اثر على
على الاقتصاد المحلي بحيث انها تدعم سلاسل
القيمه ويكون لها اثر على تمكن استثمارات
اخرى من ناحيه المضاعف الاقتصادي بالاضافه
توطن صناعات لم تكن موجوده في المملكه
تمكن صادرات وتركز على المحتوى المحلي
وتمت الموافقه في اجتماع مجلس الوزراء على
تحويل برنامج شريك الى مركز باسم مركز
برنامج تعزيز الشراكه مع القطاع الخاص
والموافقه على الترتيبات التنظيميه للمركز
البرنامج يهدف الى تنميه استثمارات القطاع
الخاص المحليه لتصل الى خمسه تريليونات
ريال بحلول عام 2030 كما يدعم توفير اكثر
من 100 الف فرصه عمل وتعزيز المحتوى
المحلي الى جانب مساعده القطاع الخاص على
المساهمه بنسبه 65% في الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بحلول عام 2030 واضافه ما يصل
الى التريليونير الى الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بحلول عام 2025
يؤثر البرنامج بشكل ايجابي وكامل على
الاقتصاد السعودي ويساهم في رفع ترتيب
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للمملكه الى
المرتبه الخامسه عشره عالميا ترجمه لاهداف
رؤيه 2030 محمد زهير العربيه
اعلنت مجموعه ام بي سي بان مسلسل معاويه
ما زال قيد التحضير واكدت ان موعد عرضه
سيتم تحديده لاحقا ونفت المجموعه صدور اي
بيانات او كتب رسميه منها وشددت ام بي سي
على ان البيانات المتعلقه بمجموعتها تصدر
رسميا عنها وتوزع عبر مكتبها الاعلامي من
مقرها الرئيس وان المصدر الوحيد الموثوق
للمعلومات المتعلقه بانتاجاتها وعروضها
وجدولها هو الشاشات ومنصاتها وصفحاتها
الرسميه فقط
[موسيقى]
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 العالم غير
مستعد على نحو كاف لمواجهه الكوارث
الطبيعيه التحذير هو من مجلس العلوم
الدولي والذي يضم عشرات المنظمات العلميه
يرى التقرير كذلك ان الحكومات غالبا ما
تتحرك بعد وقوع الكوارث وليس قبلها ويضرب
مثل مهم هنا هو التحذير من حدوث عاصفه قبل
24 ساعه قد يقلل الضرر بنسبه 30%
الى صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 يتفقد عمال
الانقاذ في اليونان عربات القطارين اللذين
اصطدمات شمال البلاد المهمه شديده الصعوبه
بين عربات تفحمت واخرى دمرت كليا او جزئيا
لم تعرف السكك الحديد في البلاد كارثه
مماثله من قبل خلصت السلطات الى ان خطا
بشريا وراء الحادث الذي يصعب تصوره
فالقطار او القطاران كانا على المسار ذاته
والتقيا وجها لوجهها
نختم هذه الساعه ولكن اخبار الساعه لا
تنقطع صهيب شراير معه الان برمجه اخبار
الساعه اهلا صهيب ماذا لديك مساء الخير
طاهر مره اخرى موضوع المسيرات الاوكرانيه
التي اقتربت من العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
سيكون معنا احد الخبراء بعد قليل من
العاصمه الروسيه يفسر لنا اذا ما كانت هذه
بدايه حرب المسيرات في العمق الروسي اليك
تفضل شكرا
[موسيقى]